what is happening there reject nation
greg and john back at it for stranger
things for volume dose can't wait to get
on this journey we're just going to
watch it all tonight drop that midnight
we're going to
go for it binge it just like the netflix
watch it giving you guys a heads up
right now that uh looking at the run
time for volume for the up the last
episode of this it's like two and a half
hours i know sometimes we do like a part
one and part two of our reaction we
might do a part one two and three
depending on how juicy that one is
because you can only show a certain
amount per video and that's why you got
to divide it up sometimes you'll be more
of a reaction you know what i mean keep
a lookout for that so with that in mind
subscribe and click that notification
bell to get notified when our reaction
for the final episode is up and leave a
like that helps us on the algorithm
leave a like for the stranger things and
for us and for whatever if you're having
a good night or day full length watch
along three seconds with the time code
available for super sexy rejects over at
our patreon page thank you all who have
joined us so far showing your support
cover a bunch of shows over there with
the same tier you get the option for
reaction highlights and watch alongs
included lastly the team at prepper
thank you guys for helping us edit down
these highlights real lastly actually i
wanted to say that we put a lot of our
like reviews and commentary based stuff
over at a real rejects podcast available
on like apple spotify wherever podcasts
are found i never shout that out but we
upload all the time to there so yeah i'm
listening to everybody so we've been
upgrading the audio here and there
anyhow finally let's get to it
[Music]
impeccable timing brenner
not so bad was it
you see
there's nothing to be afraid of
is there nancy
what
oh
no where did you take a seat
nancy hey whatever you guys are doing up
there
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
i'm with you my dude
my goodness
i want you to tell her
wow
thank god you're not jonathan
otherwise i still think i'm in a
nightmare i am 50 more relieved to see
you
[Laughter]
thought i lost you
i did lose you for eight months
[Music]
we had a funeral
anybody's show
apparently they can climb too they climb
[Music]
god damn it's like a resident evil boss
really
100
[Music]
that is disturbing is that a demo dog
oh
i feel kind of bad for it
oh
i don't feel that bad
it's out of its misery now is the most
merciful way to go
holy [ __ ] it's like aliens
so they're like oh my god growing them
or just harvesting them when they come
out here
yeah reading studying them or trying to
mutate them
trying to weaponize them right yeah
oh yeah
wow
i found something
they've seen so much [ __ ] they don't
even react to that it's like it's just
another thing now
chilling
pull me back in coach
oh she's got it all in back now huh
wow
oh
wow so long nina
[Music]
wow that's not even like a struggle for
her
[Music]
ah can't be that mad
but what if after all this is over
[Music]
she doesn't need me anymore of course
she'll still need you she'll always need
you mike she's a woman
you're scared of losing her
[Music]
can i
show you something
this is my id with my birthday card
these were the invitations my mom
printed up
it's it's hard and i know it's sort of
on the nose but but that's what holds
this whole party together hard because
i mean without heart we'd all fall apart
classic couplet
these past few months she's been so
lost without you it's just she's so
different from other people and
when you're
when you're different oh you're not
talking about l pushing you away it's
probably just because she's scared of
losing you just like you're scared of
losing her and and if she was going to
lose you i i think she'd rather just get
it over with quick l needs you mike and
she always will
oh
your speech got give me chills holy crap
damn yeah man well well it gave will a
really good vote
oh dude
oh oh dude
there's a there's a lot of personal talk
in that
right there just let him know
it's the 80s right everyone was 100
accepted yes right
and if you know people respond poorly to
say you're on cocaine
henry is putting cracks in this dam
cracks and dams
create pressure and eventually it will
reach a breaking point
and the dam will burst
hawkins will fall
well that went very well i thought you
eased her into it nice and gentle just
i'm gonna say like damn dude thickness
clock
it always chimes four times
four exactly
four kills
four gates season four summer vectors
like yeah four times that's what that's
what i meant it's actually it's pretty
slick
can't hurt them not if he's dead
we have to go back in there
back to the upside down oh god no that
terrible terrible idea when he attacks
his next victim i'll bet you he's back
in that attic physical body defenseless
defenseless yeah what about the army of
bats right true we'll have to find a way
past them distract them somehow and uh
how do we do that exactly oh you know
i can still feel him
i'm still marked
cursed
i did
try not to mess
oh damn now 11 you better get your ass
back there
[Music]
butter
what was the plane you came in on that
plane um that crash his fault
word of warning jim
i'm gonna take this i'm gonna rub it
along the bottom of my shoe and i'm
going to jam it down your throat
but then you'll never make it out of my
country
do you think fake rambo has enough guns
there is that a grenade and how is any
of this legal well lucky for us it is so
this this place
it'll take all day to bike there and
back who said anything about bikes well
you got some sort of car we don't know
about yeah it's not exactly a car it's
not exactly mine but uh
it'll do
you got a ski mask or a bandana or
something like that
[Music]
oh no way
that is great i
i'm so happy they're doing this
didn't they name drop michael myers in
this season
i think or did they allude to michael
meyer i think they kind of did some
reference earlier either way it's cool
definitely name dropped freddy maybe
jason i think michael too i'm not sure
though
yeah it all fits in
wow
[Music]
angry hillybillies
[Music]
[Laughter]
you came to me broken
and you've learned to walk again but if
you want to stop one you will need to do
more than walk you will need to do more
than run
you will need to fly yep like an eagle
to the sea
i've stopped him once and i will again
i'm sorry you can't
it's impossible nothing's impossible
you don't understand what he's capable
of well maybe you're right or maybe you
are overestimating it either way um are
you sure you want to do this
please don't die paul reiser hey no i
always had this dream that i'd have this
like this really it's really big family
i'm talking like a full brood of
harrington's like five
six kids six yeah six little nuggets
three girls three boys
and then every summer just to see the
country
you know the rockies grand canyon
maybe yellowstone
end up in some
beachside town in california
spend a week parked in the sand
learn how to search for something
that sounds nice
please don't please die don't kill steve
please don't kill screams
max i've always thought about like
having six kids
traveling the country
in an rv just like this
i just need to
push him away
find a happy memory and
hide there
hide in the light you got a memory in
mine
am i in the memory
it was the time when i was
breaking up with you
[Laughter]
oh he knows he knows
was
i there
[Laughter]
okay but the second you start to lift
calling in kate bush
all right
okay
what if they get the real kate bush to
show up i was so i
love that oh my god they've had enough
time adam sandler comedy they were
saying like we're still finishing up the
last couple episodes in the break so
maybe she was named katinka after my
first flower
catting also had very beautiful very
round
buttocks but much like this
classy
what is the furthest kichinka has ever
flown for me she is still a virgin oh
god we make a call to the states
yes we reach the states
this is the america phone
they will make the call for us and then
they will call us back
how long that could take
five minutes five hours
five days who knows season five assume
the kgb will be on the other line
listening to everything you say so
i suggest talking in code
say the wrong thing
and they will be on us like flies on
[ __ ] there's no need for you to be
menacing you know that calling owens
always leads to a very long wait time
oh
no way meet cute at the gun store
whoa
you gonna mase me with that it keeps you
in line yeah
no
no
vicky no she's a closet homosexual how
could you or bisexual hey can i see this
real pretty 357 please
holy [ __ ]
no
i forgot about this yeah
want my advice
shotguns are not good for much of
anything past killing small birds
in ar-15 but not much range
and that's just gonna force you into
close range combat and someone can just
grab that barrel
and redirect it
why are you taunting her their eyes are
everywhere oh my god hide
no jeepers christ he's in hell fire
isn't he
i don't know what you're talking about
what about his friends
they here with you
would you let go
what the hell is taking in so long
[Laughter]
gunshot sound effects
do not look out that window are you
really questioning susie right now she's
a genius jonathan even geniuses make
mistakes well she didn't if that small
woman is small enough she could fit
behind a small tree
we are having an intervention
you need to stop
you're reefers these
are no regular tire tracks bro josh i
mean look at the train on these monsters
they're fatties
and you know what that means military
we gotta go oh yeah argyle
coming in clutch
all that winds probably got to be
diluting the tracks so take us two hours
to get to nella's as it is and ellen one
more favor can he
send somebody over to a max mayfield's
house there are some kids there that
just need looking after okay
please don't die
god damn it
where's dr owens dr owens had a change
of heart
you kept henry in that lab
with the children was that for our good
was that right
i was trying to help henry to understand
him yes
yes
i cared for him even after what
papa does not tell the truth
henry said that
and now
you trust henry
henry who's manipulated you like some
puppet
has failed by you though i mean
you have risked everything
you have lied you made me look for him
the mind player
so many dead
i came here to try and understand who i
was if i was the monster it is not me
it is you
oh wow he's crying holy [ __ ]
son of a [ __ ]
oh you better kill him
wow
oh my god you guys are gonna die
i'm so worried
hear me now
there will be no more retreating
from eddie the banished
hey you're really ready for battle
hey
noah
[Music]
never change
[Music]
dustin henderson
oh
promise me i wasn't planning on it good
good good
but if we don't stop him who will
[Music]
we have to try right
yeah
[Music]
it's killing back now
slash handmaking
slash one
oh my god you sadistic [ __ ]
wow what a hell of a shot
yeah man
jesus
maybe try a discussion first
nope they're not going to discuss
nope
[Music]
oh
wow
take the collar off of her yeah you're
gonna need to set her loose man
if only there was a pizza boy
oh [ __ ]
oh yeah
oh surprise helicopter
oh my god
ah
oh my god take the caller off of 11.
please let her crash that helicopter
that is a dead papa
god are we gonna need her jack don't do
this
i'm begging you
take it you set up a bear
yeah
come on 11. oh my god
your plot line became so much better
[Music]
yes
yes
oh you [ __ ] badass
[Music]
oh wow what a great shot oh great shot
oh my god
[ __ ] holy crap
what a shot oh
wow
where's that pizza
30 minutes or it's free
oh look at that badass
oh
yeah
enola holmes
i am happy for you guys goddamn it
yes
yes
[Laughter]
bad trip dewy [ __ ]
the government's pretty pissed
was it supposed to like unlock when her
training is complete
you're ready we sent the military here
to train you eleven this was all
last trial
damn how did you survive
yeah he's been killed by democrats
i want you to know i'm proud of you
you
are my family my child
[Music]
can't give him that satisfaction man
order that pizza
[Music]
two
two
two
slightly off beat there john i know i'm
so sorry
me me me me
walk in harmony
nice owens is alive still yeah people
chills so what do you think you think we
should watch the next one i just we
should probably watch the next i'll
watch the next
like 1 30 in the morning now but we
might as well we've come this far the
journey all right guys talk about a
little bit then we're gonna immediately
film the next one
and then sleep on sunday
that's too good it's too good let's get
to it yep off to a very solid start it's
interesting i thought it might have been
like okay how's this gonna go especially
since it was like there's a volume one
and volume two that they just divided
for the sake of production budget and to
be able to finish visual effects and all
that but this really does feel like a
part two
to volume one in so many ways like the
last episode um you know the one that
revealed vecna henry uh number one
that really does feel like a final
episode now and here it feels like the
sequel to that and i really like that
five i really like that feeling like the
action-packed epic finale
even though it's like wasn't
like mainly action it has this sense of
epicness throughout because this is like
end of the world conquering stakes
vecna's gonna break out and take over
everything you know like that's the
the the beginning of this is showing
nancy like ah the upside down is gonna
be coming to the regular down the right
side of right side of
coming to hawkins prime
yeah you know and and it still feels
like a lot of it is is very much um
uh like a setup for what's to come in
the next one so i i get the sense of
like this really is mainly a setup while
there's a lot of you know development
moving forward i think the next one
seems like that's going to be the one
that's going to be like it's a
full-blown movie it's like two and a
half hours so i'm excited for that and
like the biggest development though
obviously would have to be like the very
ending moments here of setting up that
they're going to be going to kids like
max and nancy are going to be going into
the creel house and they're going to try
to kill vector themselves
smart they will do it
they're they're going to they're they're
definitely the the formidable matchup
you guys yeah you got the sinclairs and
max go into the creole house you got
everybody else going to the upside down
and between all of them
i'm sure they'll put some kind of dent
in something and you think with jason
and all that's going to cause some kind
of hiccup in their plans it's going to
cause some kind of interruption that's
going to make this even harder for all
of them but the biggest thing would have
to be you know of course
uh papa finally dying breiner
we'll see about that now he's really i
mean last time when when demogorgon got
him it was just like he might as well
still be alive yeah um but damn yeah
that's that's fine that dude could
handle some gunshot wounds holy crap
yeah that was crazy like a sniper rifle
on everything that's
bullet
keep moving that was a willpower baby i
mean it has got to be cool to be matthew
modine and to have like such a you know
i mean he is a
despicable character in certain ways he
is a complex character in many ways and
he gets a very badass outro here
yeah yeah just like the desperation and
i i love the
just the harsh
nature of their relationship and the
back and forth between the parts that
are tender and that are caring and the
ones that are clearly
so messed up well he never cared for her
as a as a person he only cared about
what he thought of her potential and her
capabilities and her powers and so i
like that
she didn't give him that satisfaction of
saying like no i understand why you did
what you did because it was thwarted
like yeah sure she is like so powerful
and all these things because of the fact
of you know she really he really helped
her hone in on her potential but i'm
glad he
died in a way that was
uh tragic for him and but i like the
conflict that millie bobby brown brings
because at the end of the day that is
pop out of her you know that is her
father figure and
uh so i i appreciated the nuance
departure of him in that moment because
yeah it is
complicated maybe not as like
wildly complex because it's like so
obvious of who brenner is but complex
for
someone like um 11 who grew up in this
imprisoned environment from this guy and
then
showed that he's not really changed at
all
and i adored that scene they have in
front of nina where they have the debate
and i think it fully sums up where
they're coming from and the the divide
that prevents them from ever truly being
connected is that that debate of no no
you didn't do this for me i mean you've
given me things yes and there are ways
in which you've helped me but you've in
large part done this for yourself and
for your need to advance this
ever
warping an ever festering situation that
you have helped to bring upon us all and
even if i opened up the upside down i
mean none of this would be here if it
wasn't for you and you continually
pushing beyond the acceptable limits and
whatnot and so yeah to have
i thought they did they've done a really
nice job especially in this season of of
really drawing a great character out of
brenner and a great relationship out of
the back and forth between him and 11
and i love owen's being in there as like
sort of uncle
in between all this like trying to keep
the peace and uh and yeah just like i
feel like there's such
strong
writing behind those things as well it's
just really terrific like it's again
it's gotta be cool to be matthew modine
and to like be at this stage in your
career and still get like
a badass gripping cathartic end to your
character and such an important role in
a show like this and the bond and the
you know the divide between him and 11
has played through him and millie bobby
brown is just so tangible and and and
you can feel all the nuances of it it's
really
quite lovely yeah and i was happy that
because i'm like i'm not back in love
with mike or something like that i mean
will's the one who got the great scene
was the one great monologue where he was
you know
literally what is that psychology word
called how are you like
uh oh my god what is something with a t
i think transference yes yes yes
yeah it's just transferring his own
feelings into this pep talk about mike
and eleven yeah yeah yeah and uh i
thought he i didn't thought it made noah
something or another noah schnapp yeah
no schnapp and did an amazing job in
that monologue because we were able to
pick up on what he was talking about but
that pain and also jonathan looking in
the rearview mirror being like yeah i
know what was really talking about
and and then for them to show up and
just to even just be a worthwhile
distraction for them to save the day i
like i like when this show does
implement that quality of fate and that
felt like that this was fake for them
just to be that one moment in time to
distract like it earned that because it
was like man they're taking a long time
to get there i mean obviously because
they don't working off an actual map
here you know
and so i appreciated the way that was
handled and so for the timing of them to
show up and to help save the day and for
her to feel like really joyful and happy
to see them
and um i thought mike would have been
like you shaved your head what
i liked you better with hair and bangs
i looked better we look like will's mom
that is the whole complex we can open up
here
but yeah
so far as it's going um i'm excited to
see what they
what they advance and i don't know i'm
just kind of like rushing through this
talk to be honest with you because i
just want to give you something yeah
saying things right now that i liked
about it because i thought it was pretty
great and i i feel like what they're
doing is they're
everyone's like having these moments
that feel like melancholic or
bittersweet and i'm going oh man i it's
what are you somebody's going to die i
want to use there's going to be some
deaths here and i don't know who's going
to have these
so tense
yes
yeah and i mean there's so much about
the the rest of the episode it's like
the 11 stuff is very revealing and
propulsive and then you have everybody
else who's just sort of on a mounting
tension and stakes mission basically to
set the stage for the final battle yeah
and so yeah you get a lot of these
moments where you're like oh god please
don't let this be the here's my girl
back home moment for steve yeah um and
uh but even all that stuff like at the
army surplus store and everyone's kind
of like on edge like i i like
the sort of mounting tension that they
have going on in hawkins and i mean for
as much back and forth as there have
been about people's feelings on the
russia storyline like i still have fun
watching them inch closer to the states
well what i'm hoping for with the run
time in the next episode that things
feel balanced i mean they're rushing to
the states but
come on we all know we know that they're
just going to leave all that [ __ ] behind
in russia they're going to do something
about it
don't introduce that and they're like we
got to get back to america i'm like no
they're going to do some [ __ ] and when
that [ __ ] goes down it's going to be
awesome
so yeah we just got to get to the second
episode guys that's it you know normally
i don't like to rush through these but i
i i i want to because i'm like we got to
get the whole because you guys are going
to be rushing to get to that yeah yeah
you're like come on
yeah um all right guys thank you for
being here subscribe click that bell
leave a like and thank you all join us
on our patreon we'll see you for the
next episode